[Music]
in the first instance we tend to answer
mosquito but that is not entirely right
malaria is not caused by the mosquito it
is only transmitted by this vector
malaria is caused by the organisms
belonging to the genus plus mo diem and
what are these organisms
well they fall in the next category of
microbes that we will be learning in
this video the third category of
microorganisms these are called the
protozoa as the name suggests proto
stands for primitive while xoan means
animal wait a second
are we saying these are organisms
primitive to animals yes they are
unicellular in nature however the single
cell has highly complex functions hence
they are also referred to as the
pinnacle of unicellular complexity so
what do you think will be the structure
well they have a typical eukaryotic cell
structure just the nucleus and the
membrane bound organelles form an
integral part of the cell many of them
possess food vacuoles which are used to
store food and these cells do not have a
cell wall are there any more special
features many of them have additional
features like Celia of flagellum for
locomotion Celia are these tiny hairlike
structures which are present throughout
the body flagellum on the other hand is
usually a slender long filament which is
single or rarely multiple in number now
this was the structure what could be the
nutrition type here we are referring to
whether they are autotrophic that is
just nourishing or heterotrophic meaning
they cannot prepare their own food we
know that these cells are like animal
cells and have mobility so do you think
they will be autotrophic like plants of
course not
these are heterotrophic in nature yes
they are dependent on other organisms as
their food source only a few rare
exceptions include the chlorophyll
containing Euglena
it usually performs photo Center
but others lack the capacity to do so
many organisms belonging to the
protozoan group are well known parasites
they derive nutrition directly from the
body of living organisms so they do not
kill the host
but do harm them severely a few commonly
known examples of protozoans include
amoeba euglena Paramecium and the
disease-causing Plasmodium this was
about the third category that is the
protozoa in the next video we will
discuss the last type that is the algae
in detail
[Music]
you